we finally got a hot tub and a
two-on-one dream is my greatest power
and wane it's time for roses and roses
a-and danke Schoen we are here to recap
Beca coupon season of The Bachelorette
and Wow this episode was a little
underwhelming wasn't it it was but let's
get into it because we can still have
fun together as a community on a journey
I'm not so amazing one this time but it
could get more amazing because the show
doesn't let us down but did it this
episode let me know what you think in
the comments okay so there are always a
lot of puns but in Vegas things are out
of control we're gonna roll the dice on
love take a gamble is my lady luck it's
Vegas baby
I think the inevitable two-on-one is
about to go down today bulton knows the
two-on-one is coming because colton
seems very familiar with this show
then Colton gets a one-on-one first
though and we see a sign that says
they're headed to Virgin River because
Colton's a virgin drink every time
you're not surprised this episode a
virgin pun I'm not surprised I'm not but
then we get another pun because Becca
says they're gonna get over the humps
get over the hump of our past
relationships camels come on camels cuz
I guess it's the desert I don't you know
Nevada but what I did love about Becca
and Colton's 101 is that we finally got
our first hot tub in the middle of
nowhere of the season I was wanting it
last week when it was cold because I
like a hot tub when it's cold I know
there's something contradictory about it
and it's like oh you're cold let it get
hot to be hot and it's great but
whatever we got it it was probably
pretty sweaty in the desert but whatever
but are we surprised to get a hot tub
and they'll know we're know or not mm-hm
we are delighted we're not surprised
Golda says there's only happened once
he's only been in love once okay I don't
know if I thought you were in love more
times than that and no judgment
I mean I just I it's what I expected
Becca says quote it was so fun so fun so
magical so different riding on a camel
and sitting in a hot tub in the middle
of the desert but it wasn't different
because it happens every season on the
show as much as my guard is up and my
walls are up and his guard is up oh I've
never heard those words before and
Colton says wait for it Becca is making
it easier
to take my walls down taking his walls
down Jordan I get to spend a special day
tomorrow
was that good and Jordan and David gets
it to you on one okay Wow in no way
shocking Wow Wow
I have to give myself sparkling these
days because otherwise I drink it too
fast it's called self awareness which
Jordan doesn't have a ton of we'll get
to it okay
so Wayne Newton is here because Las
Vegas that's not surprising we knew we
knew seems self-aware have you ever
heard of a song called that machine by
that I mean he's kind of explaining to
these people who he is I mean this group
of humans is fairly young and you know
we Newton is older and so he's like have
you heard of the song danke Schoen his
most famous song most people have heard
it but we don't know and so thank you
Wayne for educating the people but what
bothered me is that we're going to do
more songwriting which we did with Chris
and Becca at their one-on-one at Capitol
Records with the iconic Richard Marx
and I don't know we're doing the same
date again I'm surprised that it's the
same actually so I won't drink I wish it
wasn't the same concept entirely oh good
so they're writing songs and then this
time I guess they're writing sort of
cover lyrics - danke Schoen parody
lyrics I don't know what you'd call it
and I don't want to hear Lincoln talking
about love or writing love songs because
of what he did but I guess there's no
changing that I kind of wish they'd gone
back and edited those moments from him
out though you know let me know what you
guys think in the comments isn't it
weird to watch Lincoln now that we know
that he's been arrested and convicted of
indecent assault it's weird yep are you
going to wear the golden Underpants
tomorrow David and Jordan are talking
about their two-on-one and he says quote
let's not be naive there one of us is
going home well it's a two-on-one I hope
you both go home frankly I'm done I
don't need to see them talk to each
other anymore I don't even really want
to watch the two-on-one like they've
said all they can say to each other they
nitpick at each other they're squabbling
like teeny little seventh-grade boys and
I just don't need to see any more of it
but we've got two hours to fill okay
back on the group date there's an
another stack of suits for the guys to
wear on Iraq we have this on the very
first group date and it's the
performance state we always get a
performance date every season you know
in the past it's been stand-up comedy or
dancing and now it's this danke Schoen
thing here is a silver lining though you
enjoy hard
John John the software engineer venmo
guy man is this guy always in a good
mood and man as he stepped it up on
these group dates remember he killed and
I'm a lumberjack date and now he's just
sherry singing his song going along I
like you John great but that's gonna be
taken from us just like Joe was grocery
store Joe too soon
god I have high hopes for paradise ok
these poor people in the audience man do
I hope they didn't pay for this show
because all of this singing is so
terrible I was really hoping that one of
the guys would just surprised and have a
great voice you know how sometimes you
go on karaoke and somebody just turns
out to have an amazing voice but that
didn't happen
good job to Chris for having charisma
and like owning the room although I have
to say the other guy's defense Chris had
already done a songwriting date so this
was more familiar territory for him so
nobody was good it was all bad and then
somehow we wound up in a nice ring I
know I don't know if I went to the
bathroom or what but we were in an ice
rink Becca and Garrett and I you know
we've been here before again
Becca and Garrett had a conversation
next to an indoor pool for no reason and
now they're having a conversation and
next to an empty ice rink frozen water I
don't know why why are we there where
are we there are many places to go in
Vegas it's so dark and cold and
confusing it's just not my jam maybe
that's my issue with this episode get
out of there no offense mate it's just
not for me
for me anyway
we do see a cute moments between Blake
and Becca and the other guys are upset
because Blake got a lot of time with
Becca and Blake says that I'm falling in
love with Becca for quite some time how
long has it been at this point I don't
think very long I have bought in Lois
play
and I honestly knew it from the
beginning
interesting that was a good moment that
was exciting and I like Blake because he
sits back and he's not getting involved
in all the crap and he's just focused on
Becca truly unlike all the other guys
who say their focus on Becker when
they're not we're gonna continue to
drink every time we are not surprised we
are not surprised that this two-on-one
is in the middle of nowhere that's where
they always are and where extra not
surprised because didn't this look a lot
a lot like Chris soules is 201 that he
had was Ashley nobody else time for
getting oh that girl you remember her
name actually crystals even tweeted that
it looked familiar
okay like take this in like listen to
the silence you don't always get this
now it's unreal it's quiet it's so
awkward
silence crickets david says to absorb
the silence yeah I do want to soak it in
because I don't want to see you and
Jordan talk to each other anymore
you thought of the most purple thing but
they won't give us that they start
bickering Becca send them home please
these conversations are so painful and
getting a headache
[Music]
okay you know the phrase enjoy the
silence I wish I'd been able to I come
from nothing I there was times where I
didn't even have electricity okay Jordan
has a moment with Becca where he gets
kind of real and talks about his parents
but the thing is it feels like a Hail
Mary Jordan knows that Becca's really
frustrated with both of them she's told
them that and he decides to pull out
this really emotional story about his
past which I'm not saying isn't true
it's just like now now we're hearing
this you know it just didn't feel great
and then Jordans gets kind of mean I'm
actually usually surprisingly perhaps on
Jordans side because he is who he is and
I actually think David is more shady
than Jordan but then Jordan says some
mean stuff so amazed Lee and Jordan says
I think it was a lot of bleeps been a
little [ __ ] rat ass this whole time I
had to tell but that's a weird insult
you're worse than Horry and then he says
something so Jordan and so confusing
that I've got a fly in JC because with
his wondrous knowledge and worldliness
and empathy and sensitivity
he'll perhaps be able to break this down
JC thank you for joining us for our
first segment ever of on the journey
with JC where you break down the
insanity that these men say so Jordan
said quote love is the greatest power on
earth being me is my greatest power
being you isn't your greatest power
that's why
do you understand that I don't Jordan so
JC explain it to me mmm okay well it
seems that Jordans saying the greatest
power in the world is love but now
Jordan has a greater power than the
greatest power in the world which is
self-love our self-confidence and
because David does not land in that
Jordan s realm of self-love
self-confidence he's saying that David
is hating and haters gonna hate hate
hate Wow Thank You JC on the journey
with JC thank you so self-love is great
and haters gonna hate
Thank You JC David I think it's just
where we part ways Becca decides to send
David home great as I said I was on
Jordan side for most of the time but
then she says Jordan's not quite getting
the Rose yet and I really hope this
means that Jordans gonna go home too
because he's been fun but it's time see
you in paradise right you asked him
straight up the word settle over like
Jordans now why say at some point Jordan
can't let it go he's talking about David
still even though he's you know here
there Rebecca and then Jordan does this
thing that oh god don't we all love when
people do in conversations what the
weekend look like for you typically
which is ask us a question about
ourselves and then interrupt it talking
about themselves he's like what's a
weekend like for you well for me Jordan
summit it's not eternity I'm done
fortunately Zoo Enders extremely
accurate really okay and he exhibits all
of his different facial movements and I
actually enjoyed this portion because
the thing is when Jordan is being Jordan
and he's shining in his self-love I wish
we could get my portfolio out
somebody please people have what about
the Internet I know anyway
he gives back a really awkward kiss and
then because Jordan isn't self-aware he
says that the date went really well
people who love listening to themselves
talk always think the conversations went
really well
because they just listened to themselves
talk so Beca pretty matter-of-factly
sends Jordan home and my god does he
look shot what phase was that Jordan was
that the blue steel or the blue side was
that the blue steel or the blue it got
real was that the blue steel or the blue
I don't feel things anyway wait honestly
I think you owe me like fifty thousand
kisses right now Chris and Becca get in
this fight that also really confuses me
I don't really fully understand what
they're upset about if you guys felt it
made sense or you can break it down for
me like JC form in the comments because
I can you make it 50/50 every day put in
the effort every single day that's
something I don't need to think about
what I don't get that I don't get this
whole thing I'm in a Vegas bubble of
confusion where am I have you guys ever
been there you can't find anything
you're just wandering you're pondering
because they want you to stay there
spend your money Chris is like freaking
out it's all about I think this trope
that we see a lot on the show that he
didn't like try to get time with Becca
and what annoys me about Chris is that
now it's like he wants what he wants
when he wants it you know so he didn't
get his time with Becca so now he just
thinks I want my time with Becca right
now and then I don't care what I have to
do it's about me and that's annoying you
know it's like take a turn be an adult
you play there to get up will's is the
perfect person to handle this temper
tantrum from Chris God wills is growing
on me
he was so awesome on the one-on-one and
he is so often in this plaid suit and he
is singing a lot without saying much
just like I see and I mean that the best
way possible ultimately we have a rose
ceremony and Chris got a rose over John
this is Joe the grocery store guy round
two
John is great he is fun he is strong he
has a great job he's not causing any
drama and we're keeping Chris around I
think this is a situation where probably
at the end of the day things do come
down to a little bit of physical
attraction and maybe it wasn't there I
don't know I'm just supposing but bottom
line I wish that we still had grocery
store Joe and I wish that we still had
John but I'm glad that we don't have
David and I'm glad that we don't have
Jordan so in the end things are
cancelling out love is the greatest
power on earth but if you love yourself
more than that's your greatest power and
then you can control the earth just like
Jordan will one day I know I said that
out loud I shouldn't have tried to I
feel like I manifested that no we don't
want Jordan to be my control paradise I
don't know guys
what an episode as I said a bit
predictable felt like a bit of a filler
episode I still have this show of course
let me know what you think
we had some great moments with Blake and
Will's Becca and Garrett still seem to
be going strong anybody else who's still
in your mind oh cool cool I don't know
why do I tell me what you think okay I
love you guys so much thank you for
messaging me and for drinking your rosy
and doing responsibly but tell me what
your favorite Rosa is I'd love to know I
love trying new things
unlike Jordan who just likes to talk
about okay bye
[Music]
why wasn't I am Otto